字幕: Nanae Nakajima
校正: Moe Shoji
皆さんは醤油の歴史について
知っていますか
正直 私もあまり詳しく知らなかったので
今回調べてきました
醤油のルーツは中国から伝わる
醤（ジャン）であると言われています
［醤（ジャン）］
これがいつ日本に伝わったかは
はっきりとわかっていませんが
飛鳥時代に制定された
「大宝律令」によると
この頃から 醤（ひしお）が
作られたとされています
この醤（ひしお）というのは
塩蔵品の総称のことで
草醤 肉醤 穀醤の
３種類に分かれています
［草醤 肉醤 穀醤］
草醤は 今でいう漬物
肉醤は 塩辛類
そして 穀醤が醤油の原形ではないかと
言われています
飛鳥時代というと
今から1300年も前から
醤油って作られているんです
そんな昔から今も作り続けられているって
すごくないですか？
私はそんな長い歴史がある
醤油の開発者なんです
私は 長崎で生まれ育ちました
子どもの頃から
親しみのある九州の醤油は
とろ～っとして黒くて甘いお醤油です
でも 関西では色の薄い醤油が
関東では すっきりとした
辛口の醤油が好まれています
このように 醤油って
地域に根付いているものなんです
では なぜ九州の醤油が
甘くなったのか 知っていますか？
これは江戸時代
貿易の玄関口であった
長崎の出島には
たくさんのお砂糖があり
この高価な砂糖を使った料理が
最高のおもてなし とされていたこと
また 九州は海で囲まれているので
新鮮な魚が手に入りやすく
この魚の淡白な うま味を
引き立たせるために
醤油が甘くなったことなどが
理由に挙げられています
私は醤油の開発に携わって
12年になります
これまで開発してきた商品の中で
一番反響が大きかったのが
この透明醤油です
［透明醤油］
実は この透明醤油自体を
思いついたのは
今から10年前
私が入社２年目の時です
当時 減塩醤油の開発をしていて
会社独自の特許技術について
学んでいました
その時「この機械を使ったら
透明な醤油って作れるんじゃない？」
と漠然と思っていました
でも その時は商品を作ろうなんて
思いもしませんでした
醤油には1300年の歴史がありますが
その消費のかたちは
少しずつ変わってきています
それは核家族化や
女性の社会進出によって
家庭で調理をする機会が減り
外食の日常化やお総菜の充実などが
理由に挙げられています
また めんつゆや ぽん酢等といった
醤油ベースの調味料が
増えているということも
大きく影響しています
このような理由から 醤油そのものの
消費量は 少しずつ減ってきていて
ここ20年の間で約半分になっています
［醤油の「一世帯当り年間購入数量」の推移］
これらの便利な調味料を
使うと 誰でも簡単に
失敗せずに 料理を
作ることができます
忙しい現代人には なくては
ならないものかもしれません
女性の皆さん
そう思いませんか？
でも私はこのことに
少し寂しさを感じるんです
それは単に私が醤油の開発者
だからではありません
皆さん 今から質問をしますので
イメージしてもらうために
目を閉じてもらってもいいですか？
「あなたの家庭の味は？」と聞かれると
どんな料理を思い浮かべますか？
その味を思い出してみてください
正確に思い出せますか？
思い出すのが 親が作ってくれた
手料理ではないですか？
もしこれがファミレスの料理だったり
コンビニのお弁当だったら
なんとなく寂しいですよね
目を開けてください
私の会社は 醤油メーカーとして
今年 創業150年を迎えました
150年の節目の年に
これまで培ってきた技術や歴史を
もう一度見つめ直し
醤油に力を入れていくことになりました
そんな時 世間は透明飲料ブーム
私は「今 醤油を透明にしたら
売れるんじゃない？」
と思い まずは上司に
相談をしました
そしたら意外にも
「いいじゃん！ 作ってみたら」
という答えが返ってきたんです
この軽い一言がきっかけで
私の長い 透明醤油の
開発が始まりました
工場の機械を使えば 黒い醤油を
透明にできることは わかっていました
でもそのままじゃ
美味しくなかったんです
透明な色を崩さないように
味を調えること
そして その透明な色を維持することに
すごく苦労しました
また 醤油の味を崩さないように
長年醤油を作ってきた
先輩方の意見を大事にして
慎重に開発を進めていきました
皆さん 醤油といえば和食ですよね
でも 醤油をもっといろんな料理に
使ってもらいたかったので
ある程度 商品として
形になってきたときに
和食ではなく
あえて洋食のシェフに
味や 使ってみた感想を
聞きに行きました
そしたら「コンセプトは
いいけど 少し甘すぎる」
という指摘があり
料理への使いやすさや
色んな方に受け入れてもらえるよう
関東向けのすっきりとした醤油の味を
意識して 味の調整を行いました
試行錯誤を繰り返し
１年半の年月をかけ
2019年2月19日
透明醤油を発売しました
透明醤油の作り方
知りたくないですか？
ここで 簡単に紹介したいと思います
［透明醤油の作り方］
まずは大豆と小麦を原料にして
麹菌 酵母 乳酸菌などの
微生物の力を利用して
濃口醤油を作ります
この工程までは 普通の醤油を
作るのと 全く変わりません
この後 透明にする工程
そして味を調える工程を経て
商品が出来上がります
何も新しい機械を使うことなく
これまでの技術を応用して
透明醤油は誕生しました
洋食のシェフからは
「透明だから素材の色が変わらず
醤油味を生かしたメニューが作れる」
という評価を頂きました
他にも お子さんが
いらっしゃる家庭からは
「こぼしても汚れなくていい」
という声がありました
発売前からテレビなどでも
取り上げていただいたこともあり
SNSを通して一般消費者からの
反響が大きく
私は毎日投稿を確認するのが
楽しみになりました
#透明醤油 とすると
今1000件以上の投稿が
上がっているんです
また国内だけではなく
海外からも注目され
今７つの国や地域に輸出しています
［中国 香港 台湾］
［シンガポール カナダ
オーストラリア マレーシア］
皆さん 実際に透明醤油で
料理を作るとどうなるのか
想像できますか
３つ動画を準備しましたので
一緒に見てみましょう
先に言っておきますけど
これはしゃぶしゃぶではないです
今の 何の料理か わかりました？
そうです　すき焼きなんです
意外とありじゃないですか？
これをすき焼きと言ったら
インスタ映え間違いなしです
（笑）
次は刺身に付けたときです
ふつうここ 黒ですよね
お皿に入っているのは
水じゃないです
刺身に付けても 色が付きません
ちなみに 透明醤油に
わさびを溶いてみると
こんな鮮やかな緑色になります
［わさび醤油］
インパクトありますよね
でも安心してください
ちゃんと味はわさび醤油です
他にも 冷奴にかけてみると
こんな感じです
もう一度言いますけど
これ水じゃないです
どれだけかけたか わかりづらいのが
ちょっと難点です
（笑）
透明醤油は 和食の枠を超えて
素材の色を重視する料理にも
使ってもらえるようになりました
この料理すべてに醤油を使っているんです
これ 何かわかりますか？
そう みたらし団子です
次は これ
ただの刺身じゃないですよ
これはマグロの漬けです
（笑）
マグロに色がついていないので
新鮮に見えますよね
だんだん皆さん醤油を使って料理を
作りたくなってきたんじゃないですか
世の中にはたくさん
便利な調味料が溢れていて
誰でも簡単に料理を
作ることができます
でも 誰が作っても同じ味に
なってしまうんです
実際 私も普段仕事をしているので
ついつい便利な調味料には頼りがちです
でも 時間に余裕がある時は
母から教えてもらったレシピで
料理を作ったり
味を見ながら 自分がしっくりとくる味で
味付けをしたりします
長崎に帰って母の手料理を
食べると ほっとするよう
自分でその味が作れると
なんだか安心します
私は透明醤油をきっかけに
皆さんにも 一から醤油を使って
あなたの家庭の味を
思い出してもらえたら嬉しいです
なぜなら あなたの家庭の味って
あなたの家にしかないんです
同じ肉じゃがでも 思い出す味は
それぞれ違うんです
ありがとうございました
（拍手）